[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return the return episode it was like
seven years ago that Jeanette McCurdy
the incredible Jeanette McCurdy did this
podcast but Katie uh made me aware of
her new book which is called I'm glad my
mom died and uh obviously I was like
what I gotta read this checked it out
actually I listened to the audiobook
it's unbelievable it's incredible she's
so talented she's so wonderful I was
like we have to have her back on the
podcast so definitely check out I'm glad
my mom died as an audiobook is how I did
it Katie read the book either way same
words but her performance is really
really great she's so talented so this
is an incredible chat obviously we joked
in this episode that it's like perfect
for the holidays because there's a lot
of talk about how difficult uh family
Dynamics can be in relationships like
that and how to mend them and how to
heal them and anyway it's really a
wonderful chat one of my favorites in a
long time so let's get to it as quickly
as possible this episode will be on
YouTube but because of some technical
difficulties where the video didn't work
out we're just releasing it as audio on
YouTube and also as an audio podcast so
uh that's I don't know I just wanted I
didn't want you to be confused but you
can still watch it on YouTube if that's
if that's how you [__] with podcasts uh
if you'd like to see me uh live doing
stand-up comedy come go come go to
feedhomes.com some new dates are also
about to be added but right now you can
go uh for tickets to San Francisco
Portland Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and
Washington DC and I'd also like to point
out that it being the holiday season
it's a wonderful time to treat yourself
or someone you love to a Pete's pick
like I'm holding it right here magic
mind it's always here on my desk you
hear me offer it to the guests because I
loved magic mine first I reached out to
them my dear friend James Bashar it's
how we became friends uh is the
developer of magic mind I loved it then
I reached out and was like you guys
gotta sponsor the podcast get a promo
code to the weirdos so the love was
first that's super important because
this is the product that has changed my
life the most in recent years I
absolutely absolutely swear by it and if
you've tried it recently or or never
tried it I'd like to point out they just
put out a new version It's version 4.0
which tastes even better uh it's less
shaking required meaning the matcha
that's in this drink you don't have to
shake it as much it gets mixed up easier
and it gets into your system faster
meaning you feel the effects faster so I
already loved it but they're always
working on it tweaking it and proving it
on version 4.0 is now available and I
absolutely love it you maybe heard me on
we made it weird I drank one and talked
about the new taste but that was the
first time and now I'm hooked on version
4.0 if you don't know what it is it's a
magical Elixir that makes you focus
better on your work be more creative and
drink less coffee in fact you drink it
with your coffee because it has
adaptogens in it and adaptogens round
the edges of stress sometimes coffee can
make you a little stress this rounds out
that experience and makes it just pure
clean Creative Energy it's a mix of 12
functional ingredients including as I
mentioned matcha nootropics that help
you focus and adaptogens as I mentioned
help you fight off stress everybody has
you know athletes everybody athletes
have Gatorade we jokingly call this
creatorade it's Creator raid you take it
with your coffee or on its own which is
often what I do for a sharper mind
steady energy immune support and less
stress you get 30 percent more done on
average five to seven hours of 30
percent more productivity after drinking
it doesn't get you wired this is the
biggest point it doesn't get you wired
or jittery it gets you dialed in which
makes it your Creator's best friend you
try it 15 minutes before you're doing
something and you just have so much more
ease getting into that flow State
getting into that dialed in state fights
off some ADD symptoms procrastination
brain fog and fatigue I absolutely love
it I swear by it give it a try perfect
way to support the show if you like the
show go to
www.magicmind.com who has time for that
m dot Co slash weird and use disco
discount code weird at checkout to get
20 off it's a limited time 20 off your
first order magicmine.com weird weird at
checkout it's also brought To Us by our
friends which I'm also wearing this is
my Apollo neuro I was just leaving for
LA the other day and realized I wasn't
wearing my Apollo is charging and I
turned around I was like 10 minutes away
from my house I turned around came back
to the house just to get my Apollo it is
a wearable piece of technology a lot of
people think it's a watch or something
like a whoop it is not it is way better
than either of those things because it
sends gentle vibrations directly into
your nervous system basically speaking
to your nervous system in the language
of touch which is the language that it
can understand it's basically a wearable
hug it's like a robo hug they could have
called it Robo hug like robot hug who
has time for that tea I have a lot of
who has that time jokes in this intro
but it gives your nervous system the
signal that it is okay and that it is
supported it's like a weighted blanket
that you wear all the time helping you
feel safe and in control I wear it on my
wrist thou wears hers on her ankle it
delivers those gentle almost
sub-perceptual meaning you don't notice
it but you notice the effects of these
vibrations that train your nervous
system to recover and rebalance after
stress and in my experience help you
while you're feeling that stress also
like one of the settings is called sleep
and renew as I'm older now I get up more
in the night uh to to go PP and when I
get back in bed sometimes it's hard to
fall back asleep I just hit these two
buttons on the Apollo it runs that
program again sleep and renew and
literally lulls Me Gently back to sleep
by basically like establishing a pattern
and then slowing that pattern down and
then you're off they have the opposite
of that which is energy and wake up
Social and open is also a more upbeat of
sensation helps you get into those group
modes into that creative mode clear and
focus has been shown to help fight off
symptoms of ADD rebuild and recover is
what I put it on after stressful things
like flights or difficult phone calls or
meetings relax and unwind we call it the
try to stay awake setting that's what I
have it on at night when I'm watching TV
or reading getting ready for bed as I
mentioned sleep and renew a polynero
works better the more you use it it's
not woo-woo as I always point out this
isn't like a crystal it was developed by
a neuroscientist and a board-certified
psychiatrist who have been studying the
impacts of chronic stress for nearly 15
years and Apollos effects on stress
sleep cognitive performance and Recovery
have been proved proven in multiple
clinical trials and real world studies
so don't just take it from me this is
the The Cutting Edge of wearable
technology and it's absolutely changed
my life I've given it a way more apology
it's an incredible Christmas holiday
gift that if you don't know what to give
somebody the answer is the Apollo so get
10 off and show your support of the show
go to apollonuro.com weird that's APO
l-o-n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird for 10 and
show your support of the podcast all
right everybody enjoy this incredible
chat with Jeanette McCurdy and I really
really hope you're having a great
holiday season we'll be taking next week
off but we will see you on Friday for we
made it weird and then we'll be back in
the New Year all right get into it
I like monster socks because the shoes
are too big why are you embarrassed I
mean I actually think this is the
highest compliment Leela who's my
four-year-old would love everything
you're wearing oh I love that right
that's great why not why not well we're
as you know uh the show just starts as
long as it's okay if it was your sock
material being yeah for sure
reading your book so I maybe you're
getting this like I feel like this like
sensitivity like I want to be really
gentle and kind to you like even Katie
was like she said I loved her book I
read in two days
it's such a weird thing to be like and
we loved it you know what I mean
you know what I'm saying sure but like
when I saw you I had like this new
obviously you did the podcast before
years ago but now there's this new
appreciation I hope that's not like
rubbing you the wrong way are you
getting that from people I appreciate it
the only thing that I don't really like
is
um oh God I just want to hug you yeah
that makes me feel like that I'm being
pitied and I'm like oh God that's not
yeah I'm I'm good on that kitty is
pity's an interesting thing right I mean
it's sort of like improv yes ending your
victimhood yeah is that what it feels
like yeah and it feels and to me it
feels like that's not I would have never
um sort of done written about my life if
I if I just wanted pity like I thought
that there was something entertaining
about it I thought there was something I
thought that I could write good story
and I I it feels sort of like to me it
feels like it's been kind of undermined
if it's just like oh the pity well it's
also loaded isn't it it's going to Jump
Right In no no no totally do you have
any coffee this morning just be silly
yeah there's a water right there
um this is so fancy that's we were just
talking about it this is our new water
it's Nirvana Water and it's made by a
doctor who was treating patients and
they were having a hard time holding
onto their muscle like you know how
people that are sick obviously I was
like this will be interesting to mention
to Jeanette but it decreases muscle loss
reduces Muscle Recovery time and
strengthens muscles and bones and
doesn't taste bad it's got orange in it
right yeah yeah
I'm glad yeah it's called Nirvana there
are new there are new ones
yeah I'm glad you enjoy it's our first
literally our first step out so anyway
yeah that's my point is I'd like to
start with like more casual water banter
and all the things that have changed me
too it's good yeah yeah well then let me
Jump Right In because it has to be
loaded that your mom
used so much of her diagnosis to get
specialness yeah so if you wrote a book
it would be like oh no she learned
nothing you know what I mean exactly
yeah we would all understand and would
just kind of say it behind your back
it'd be like well the Apple doesn't fall
apart you know what I mean like what a
nightmare
I'm so glad you left because I'm like no
one thinks that but like
but now that you've said it people no no
we're we're dispelling because it's so
clearly not written
look I look back on my book and there's
certain things that I wrote about my
parents that were just a little bit when
was your book it came out
right when Lilo was born so about three
years ago oh my god oh I'll give you one
there's one on the Shelf
um it's but like there are Parts I wrote
about my parents I do not regret it but
I can tell that I'm going like
pretty [__] sad right you know what I
mean like I'm trying to get the base
coat and when I read yours you have this
license like like James Bond you have a
license to like go for tears and stuff
like James Bond
yeah but it's not blood that drips down
it's tears it's transl you can't really
tell it just looks like goo but it's
tears I just wanna I want you to know no
one no one feels like I'm so glad I'm so
glad to hear that why so tell me a
little bit more about why
the catharsis I mean do I need to hold
this close also is this okay kind of
here okay great in fact let me start
with the is it hard to promote this is
the first thing I wanted to say is it
hard to promote a book because you go on
the morning radio you go on lots of
things dumb things you're like so do
that but Carter you're glad your mom
died tell me Jeanette why are you glad
oh yeah that your mom am I reading this
it's like Chico and the boy am
I and one day your mom oh my God like
right the title is great I mean I I love
it because I respond to that sort of
honesty but you must be getting that
like crazy uh yeah it's definitely been
so this feeling
Chico I'm the boy isn't he coming up
next after the break Jeanette McCurdy's
glad her mom died I wonder how she died
my mom died I wouldn't be so glad let me
tell you that right now well I love my
mom in fact we're gonna call her after
the break and we'll let Jeanette talk to
my mom who is alive okay we'll be right
back
can I tell you I've been on radio shows
where they call someone from Orange is
the New Black and they're literally like
you guys get naked a lot in that show
and the woman hung up on them I forget
which actors I love that but I was like
that I respect that get the [__] off
this car that's what he's that was his
first question was like you gotta take
your tatas out and I was like click and
they were like I think we lost her yeah
you [__] you [__] lost her you idiot
so tell me is that your experience
crying oh my God
[Laughter]
honestly before like I wasn't even sure
like doing press for something like this
felt weird like I didn't I I felt like
[__] I shouldn't I don't know if I
should do that and
um and I just I I had a lot of doubt and
um but ultimately my manager sort of
convinced me to do it and I trust him a
lot and he felt like you know this is
just gonna it's just gonna help so much
and like you need to do this
um can I Echo that yeah I mean when
Katie this is all Katie by the way I'd
have you on anytime anytime you're
welcome on the show anytime thank you
but she was like I don't know if you
know Jeanette wrote a book and we love
talking about parent issues and I slow
gas leaked it like I didn't want to like
fully come out like about you know you
feel weird yes Family secret yes and
then like that is the maybe it tied for
first number one thing other than like
spiritual trauma but that's tied into
your story but people are like you share
it it helps you and it helps them yes
it's like a miracle it helps everybody
yeah so I'm truly glad you did oh so
keep going thank you no thanks I
appreciate it
[Laughter]
um and then yeah so so I started doing
press and I did have a lot of the yeah
the sort of radio voice which is just
such a weird layer especially
considering the things I'm talking about
and like growing up in Hollywood and all
of that it's like the irony of it yeah
and the humor was it was like funny to
me I remember did I probably shouldn't
say this but Good Morning America and it
was like 15 seconds yeah and they and
they they like load I'm like being
loaded into the set while they're
already recording another second always
noon yes it's always hard noon it's like
a wild west noon like no clouds good
morning everyone America and I'm sorry
to keep interrupting with the Reps we're
going to get back to it but is there
anything more like a bad psychedelic
trip than a good morning like not just
good morning America but morning shows
in general there's something really
unnatural yes about smiling when you're
not happy and shiny
and it's nice to see the host realize
that the title of your book is so sad
because they're like coming up next on
Good Morning America Jeannette Jeanette
McCurdy is here to talk about how her
mom
I'm glad my mom died and like just
Trails off as they're reading the
prompter oh my God yes KFC is out with a
new flavor that might be a little too
spicy and Jeanette McCurdy from iCarly
is glad that her
her mom died
that after message from the wacky
weather Jesus Christ
off camera
I'm sure they have it more than a few
times right um the woman who was like
announcing or present or like
introducing the segment she was going on
and on about my like terrible life while
I'm being kind of loaded in and like
trying to be quiet and they're like like
pipe down because I was wearing like
loud boots and they're like trying to
get me to be more quiet and she's like
her terrible brutal awful horrendous
like just a string of adjectives going
on and on about how kind of brutal my my
life was and I sit down opposite George
Stephanopoulos we found out like the day
before he was going to be doing the
interview instead of you know it wasn't
like the light segment they thought it
was going to be it was like a serious
sit down and the whole thing just felt
like God this is this is bizarre this is
um this is sort of
yeah like it's just it's it's just a
weird like meta version of the thing
that I'm talking about in the book
you've been reduced to bullet points yes
yes exactly exactly it's very
dehumanizing yes I'm a Good Morning
America please have me back hold up you
know what I mean like I'm so grateful
thank you so much I love always noon I
love a bad psychedelic trip it's so fun
but I'm just saying when you are just
not the same but on crashing they would
be like he was raised religious and then
his wife left him here to talk about it
and I'd be like oh thanks so much yeah
they just they they sort of inherently
lack Nuance which I get as part of it
but the idea of like okay I'm sort of
participating in this thing yes which
how much does that suggest that I'm
endorsing this thing well also I know
that I have to do this thing for the
thing to do well it's like that's right
it was really kind of I I had I did a
lot of therapy specifically around press
and like how to navigate that
um and then I actually noticed last
night I was feeling some I was so
excited to see you guys you both
um but I was feeling some dread and I
was like what is this dread about why am
I feeling this like and I think it's
just from talking about it so much and
that I've become somewhat desensitized
to it I think and I think that then
makes it just less I think it makes it
less interesting to hear and I think it
makes it less
impactful to even talk about like I felt
I feel like there's something of a lack
of connection just by nature of I like
cried a couple times in press I felt
some Shame about that so then I felt
like I had more of a guard when I would
talk about it and kind of be more the
presentational version of myself in
order to get through talking about a
thing without choking up because I'm
like [__] I know how they're gonna edit
it and they're gonna make it seem like
like
grainy black and white like a like an
off-angle camera you didn't know they
were shooting on she never really breaks
down yes yes and then the thumbnail on
YouTube like I knew that was how things
were going to be sort of Yeah just they
they and I get that they're doing that
because they have to because they want
the views but um yeah yeah we can all
puke in our mouths for what you just
said you know what I mean I'm not even
trying to be funny it reminds me of how
one of the things that really haunted me
uh is how kids learn to justify their
parents Behavior so anything and I think
it's probably why you have this aversion
to it anything that sounds like yeah but
you know they're just being a good show
you know what I mean
chilling and as a father now I was like
oh my God like don't forget I don't
forget yeah if there's anything I can
say about Valentine's parenting Styles
we don't forget that Lila's watching and
paying attention as best we can she's
four she's four yeah I know two years
older than when you said you were two
and singing but here's let's keep on
what you're saying okay
this is going to sound I've had good
experiences profound experiences that
get turned into a story yes and Louis CK
I know but he has this thing about
stand-up where he's like there's there's
dictating like reading a script and then
there's communicating and it's different
sides of the brain and I when I heard
him say that that really changed how I
do stand up I try to perform from a
communicating Place interesting and I
think what's happening and you tell me
is you have this wet stone of something
to share and you walked it back to the
beach blanket and it dried up because
you have to talk about it so much I
don't understand walk me through a wet
stone okay here we go we're gonna stay
with it okay great I'm just saying in
talking about it so much it becomes
words instead of and it's a
self-preservational thing somehow that's
the wet dry Stone no one no one called
that into you either got it or you
didn't man but like I I've had beautiful
experiences that when people ask me
about them and bad experiences yes yes
you hate that you go like well this is
the time I saw a dead body and and it
becomes you turn yourself into bullets
yes yes yes you have to right but isn't
there like
and you tell there's a leading question
but when you write about it there's
almost the good version of that because
you're putting it on paper and you're
making it words there's like a healthy
distance yeah but then in the repetition
it becomes
stale or too distant yeah I'm already
self-conscious of how pretentious this
is but also like the way can I just say
can't wait
it's like it was my genuine thought and
I was like [__] whatever whatever it
is I'm gonna yes Sam the pretentiousness
so hard like the writing of the thing
you know if it's a personal experience
feels like there's some crafting
involved like there's some there's
commitment to it there's the time and
energy and effort it takes to like
really consider what's entertaining and
what's not but then just
talking about the thing that you've made
then that to me just feels really just
kind of it's starting to feel a little
vapid yeah um it's twice removed right
it happened right and you wrote about it
then you talked about what you wrote
about yeah and the writing about it felt
pure like I really mean that like it
really felt pure to me it really felt
um it felt I felt compelled to write
about it I felt really connected to it
and now I'm just like okay I I
I I there's nothing one there's nothing
else to say there's no other like I'm
not gonna say something in a better way
than I wrote it for then I spent writing
it for a year and a half and then now if
I say something it just like I'm
rehashing and I'm re yeah it just feels
tired by the way every author that comes
on it sucks that you're like so uh
someone who wrote the book committed and
we're like what's it mean to commit and
you're like I wrote the book the book is
the answer right right now you have to
go around I guess what I'm trying to say
is like I'd love to find a way to talk
about it with but we don't have to
directly talk about it like I really
don't want to be like so why are you
glad you know what I mean right right
right right right if I so I'll steer it
and we can talk about whatever you want
I'm really excited to talk with you
about spiritual the spiritual elements
and all that because I know there's
exactly I assume I think there's a
connection there there is well
God I I again I'm being very sensitive I
keep wanting to say white glove but
that's not right why is it exciting
still it's like Downton Abbey I'm not
treating you like a giant dining table
I'm a kid gloves maybe yeah yeah sure
what are we going to say
um the sensitivity yeah I feel I feel I
feel right what's the Worst That Could
Happen what if I just started crying
like whatever who cares right I mean be
fun well then we'd work through it yeah
you're right and by the way Max this is
your episode Well we'd edit out anything
well I I genuinely do I feel I feel safe
here and I feel like we're gonna have a
I hate that you know that word whatever
but I do feel like it's uh yeah at this
point it's lost its meaning right I
actually maybe I've had a lot of
therapists reach out and they're like
we've noticed that you say you're in a
safe space and they're like we think
that's really good and I'm not doing it
to manipulate interesting yeah yeah but
I benefit when people just say like just
like call it out you're safe it's okay
like this isn't a gotcha podcast yes yes
yes yes yes yes and that's totally true
you could make this 20 minutes if you
want at the end of the day but what I
was worried that I'm doing is people
projecting on or or over sharing
making it about them making your story
about them but in the interest of
talking about it I like that I like it
to me it feels makes it feel more
conversational and makes it feel less
you know kind of pointed and like well
so here's my question for you you know
what I'm saying well that's what I hope
it feels like yeah when I was reading it
well I'm listening to it and you did a
great job and the writing is fantastic
and here's a very uh surface compliment
I love short chapters and you feel like
you're ripping through yes yes and it
never gets caught in the mud there's no
fat I'm so glad I'm so glad there's no
like all right move on you're just like
I can't believe you ended there like
it's not even my life I would have been
like I would have written so much more
not in a good way you end it wanting
more and then you have to read the next
chapter yeah I have such a short
attention attention span when I read
that I really wanted it to be sort of
feel digestible and um
and just yeah readable I wanted it to
not feel
too long like I'll get so distracted in
the middle of a chapter if a chapters
like 10 pages I'll think okay I'll get
to the end of it and then I'll kind of
go do something else and then I'll wind
up just getting I just feel like oh it's
too much to read these 10 pages and then
I'll go get distracted and watch
something or you know do the dishes and
then forget about it it's actually and
it's kind of um people sometimes say use
the word graceful wrong I mean full of
grace meaning understanding of the
reader meaning I'm telling you something
difficult what is graceful what is the
wrong graceful I think when people say
graceful they mean like Elegance
I mean full of grace like compassionate
might be a better word that it's like
let's not let's not go nuts let's do a
little little segments yeah and you can
take a break whenever you will take it
little Skittles
yeah okay so let's talk about this and
then we'll talk about what our favorite
candy is so we'll do like little palette
cleansers
spoiler mind Skittles
nothing it's not it's not it's not
um I really related hard and I know this
is General to feel the feeling of a
child being responsible for the
happiness of a parent and I know that's
yeah pretty on the nose if you've read
the book sure but like
I don't know I I there's something about
realizing and being told my mom you know
we're doing pretty good but like she
still will say like you're the only
thing that makes me happy and I I did
something crazy where I we Val and I
were in the car together and I was like
I just want to call my mom I have no
other time to do it do you want to
listen and she listened have you did you
ever do something like that or there's a
witness and you're like no this is weird
I know this is weird yeah and my mom who
knows I'm not coming home for Christmas
by the way I spent a lot of my time
being feeling sad and feeling loving so
I'm not just sure get over it dumbass
like it's not that and you're usually
with her for Christmas this is no no
okay okay we usually alternate but now
that we have the baby it's like
we just want to make it about Lila not
fly to Boston sure sure and if I'm being
real and this is the hardest part then I
think we all kind of know nobody likes
it nobody enjoys it no one wants it
exactly for sure including them yes
Jeanette yes I know right now friendly
list four year fourth birthday yeah my
dad
for everyone to hear we're cutting the
cake and my dad's he's always
perpetually pulling up his pants he's
just going all right he's shuffling over
in his Tevas and if you saw my dad's
feet you would see what a bold Choice
tivas are my dad is my foot his foot
takes a left like there's it's just like
it's like two feet he's going in two
directions in one foot and he's like
I'll wear the most open toe sandal and
he's pulling up his pants and he goes
fourth and my Val's parents are there
and he goes four thousand miles for a
lousy slice to cake
and I'm like if you're not enjoying this
who is this for right like right it
really becomes to a certain extent where
it's like you wanna this is so brutal to
say so I'm over sharing I'm like
we enjoy our Christmas and and you'll
come and you won't enjoy our Christmas
yes so it's just a loss I hate what I'm
saying right now but nothing is good I
couldn't agree more right yeah so when
it's like do you why aren't you coming
for Christmas there's these like you
talk about in the book there's unspoken
family things one of our own spoken
family things is like we don't really
work
we don't work and by unspoken I mean
sometimes I do say that yeah are you
Seinfeld voice but I have to be like we
don't work do you feel do you I feel
I've felt that a lot recently I was
trying to figure out how to spend
Christmas with my brothers we haven't
spent it all together since our mom died
and um I thought there's some part of me
that thought like that became a child
and thinking oh it's going to be this
healing beautiful wonderful experience
we'll all be together we'll all get
through it and then just working through
like literally the second I sent the
email thread to all three of them I was
like what have I done like why did I
start this and then realizing kind of uh
I I that I don't think any of them want
to really be there either and I can feel
them kind of making excuses for doing
and just being like let's just not make
this happen like none of us want to do
this but why that can't be said and why
we have to pretend that we want it and
then also just like the sadness that
it's not that we're not really that
close and that we're not really that
connected and that we don't really have
much in common it's like it can be
really sad I know we're talking about a
sad thing but I'm like really happy
because so much of life is not talking
this way yeah and it drives me crazy yes
and what we're talking about is what
Val's therapist would say because
sometimes Val talks about me in therapy
which if I'm being honest I'm like
that's so nice
but you devoted a little time for like
on your shoe like really what did she
say but she she was talking about this
and it was like
she she would say like you have to and
Val would say you have to like mourn
like while you're saying it it's like
the little girl Jeanette yes and the
little boy peed yeah that wants it to
work yeah and now I could make myself
cry but I remember saying to my dad
I was just in one of those heart open
moments yes like a Moment of clarity and
I was sitting with him and I was like we
should we should take a road trip me you
and my brother
oh this is brutal
have this pillow
and he looked at me and was like yeah oh
[__] but the subtitles on it would be
like his line would be dad the reader in
parentheses knowing it's never gonna
happen would be his Direction Pete
knowing it's never going to happen Dad
we should take a road trip it would
actually say Earnest yet knowing it'll
never yes yes and like coming to terms
with that one of the only ways I have to
come to terms with it is having these is
conversations like this where I'm like
there's unspoken family mythologies one
is never admit that we don't work
act like we work but we all know it
doesn't work yes brutal yes brutal
um
it makes me think of well a couple
things but there's also like the the
things that you then have to say to like
reiterate you know in in person I don't
know I feel it's it's so difficult for
me to do the the thing that I know I
should do for example like one of my I
have two sister-in-laws one of my
sister-in-laws will do the thing of like
we're always here for you like we love
you so much in this thing and I I feel
and none of them will ever ever watch
this which is why I feel comfortable
saying it um but uh but I guess you know
if they did
we'll figure it out if they did
meandies.com weird please just sell
three I'm just kidding I just want them
I mean if they're gonna watch and
complicate your life they might as well
support the podcast they're not gonna
see it
they avoid they avoid they tend I've
noticed that they sort of avoid anything
where I'm talking about the childhood
stuff it's just it's difficult for them
and they they you know one of them is
has been in therapy the others really
aren't and aren't ready for it and don't
really kind of want to go near it but
um but can a worms thing right I don't
want to open the can horns yes open the
worms it's so yeah that's its own thing
yes that's its own thing I didn't mean
to interrupt but no no no no no
perspective towards therapy is so
confusing oh my God they're worms
they're not going to eat yeah the
metaphor is actually quite right it's
just worms yeah let them out there you
go it's
um yeah but I feel like I can't do that
thing of like it feels so put on to me
if I were to go and like grab them by
the shoulder and be like God we're just
here for each other like I can't get
through the thing that I feel like would
give them some sort because they're
doing it to me but I feel them also
wanting it from me and wanting that like
you know reassurance of that we are a
family and we're here for each other and
it's not that I I
I I think we would all be there if we
needed one another for for one reason or
another but
it's not there's it's just not we don't
we don't want to that if there's just a
disconnect there's just a fundamental
kind of we just are not
you know in harmony we're not uh they
can't find the right way of saying it
but very different people yes and why
wouldn't we be yeah we are very
different people some families luck out
or they bond or I don't know what the
[__] they do yeah can I do you relate to
this because as you're saying that that
Wishful hope yeah
when if I am oh God this makes me want
to puke if I'm at my absolute best and
my best I mean my perfect which is a big
theme in your book which I also was it's
when I'm driving I go oh God I'm like
out loud saying oh God but the concept
of perfect yeah meaning
don't feel how you feel just let the the
positive Pleasant emotions be a tarp
over everything else and if you dance as
fast as you can and put on a show then
the family can sort of appear to work
yeah it literally makes me uncomfortable
talking about it I feel about my whole
body yeah yeah when I said I could puke
I'm not joking it's like so I'm being
asked and again I don't want to sound
too pretentious but in the in the hopes
that people listening can relate and we
can all be healed a little bit is I did
I do still I'm 42 43. I'm one of those
I'm 43 I think 143. I feel like the
rodeo clowns that like come out and calm
down the Bulls and like I don't want to
jump in a barrel and like honk my nose
and and and like I have to like do a
character yeah yeah I said this on stage
once and I'm going to throw this back to
you but when I go to to Boston to do
shows
I'll be like I've been speaking in a
fake Boston accent the entire time with
my family because that's the only like
it helps me like cope I'll be like Jay
Holmes how are you big guy like just
this ridiculous character yeah ah Jay
what a pain in the ass Joe Lombardo your
own like doing his jokes to him yeah
yeah and he's laughing and then going to
my mom being like what a pain in the ass
that is am I right look at him he didn't
even care about you call it flower it's
the only move the only move is like
bazooka shots like you can't go in you
have to like kick in the door and like
mow everybody down with bits and
everyone like laughs and then before you
know it it's over but you go home and
you feel like you feel drained exhausted
you feel used you feel dishonest all of
this stuff so I would feelings oh my God
there's got to be a word for it I bet in
like Germany they have a word for it you
mean you had a little bit much snake in
the [__] snake in a [__]
I have taken a [__] so I say on stage
just and put it back to you I go I've
been speaking in a fake Boston accent
for the past let's say three days and no
one in my family has noticed
[Music]
not one of them goes like can what is
this voice right what's going on man
what are you doing yeah yeah like
totally again this is just the Jeanette
and Pete make you make themselves almost
cry episode but if someone went like
Pete are you uncomfortable like you know
what I mean like yeah it seems like you
feel like you have to perform we can
just sit and eat and like how are you
and like it looks like a real like how
are you let me tell you a little bit
about my day yes it doesn't work that
way in fact watching sitcoms I'm talking
too much no no you're from those types
of shows yeah I would watch shows like
that and be like like Blossom and the
dad with his high 80s 90s jeans would be
like Blossom you seem a little off I'm
like if somebody said you seem off
like they know what Baseline is like it
was just bazooka bits bazooka bits and
Golden Child tell me everything what
would have
what how you did say that like at a
gathering or something if somebody
really just like saw you for a second do
you what would what would it lead to the
real heart rate with my mom I could my
mom and I could have a real chat yeah
and my dad it's very rare it's almost
like the these clouds part and you find
a moment and you can connect but you
better be talking about how great it is
to win and how it sucks to lose and how
hard work is great and uh aren't we
better than other people like you these
are my these are the heads yeah without
really saying for sure you know when
they ask like how's blah blah blah doing
it's just like you doing better than
them
it's like how I scroll through Instagram
which is why I don't it's like where am
I in relation to this person yeah that's
not always but there's that voice in my
head sure but if my dad asked
Bill like really what's going on I
wouldn't feel safe to answer because I
would know five seconds in he might just
start going like am I off
what what does it mean for me to be off
yes if Peter's off
where am I and he'd come back and I'd be
like and that's probably the most
vulnerable thing I've ever said and it'd
be like
go socks or something like he just it's
not even his fault it's just not on the
menu right tractor beam I hear you I'm
listening and I'm I'm not just guessing
what you might say I'm actually
listening to what you are saying yes yes
oh my God schneichen Franklin
too much too much sneaker flocking what
what do you got I'm talking too much you
know I'm sorry please no I'm now I'm
just thinking I'm honestly I'm I'm doing
exactly the thing that your dad would be
doing so now I'm thinking about my sort
of my my situation with my brothers and
what to I want to like solve it I want
to fix it I want to
um I mean honestly the other day I was
figuring out what to do and I just like
I I was talking to my significant other
and I felt like
I said like I just I just can you just
decide because I just feel like it's too
I feel overwhelmed anytime my family
comes up I feel completely like my
decision making I just can't make very
simple decisions I can't do it it's
freeze I feel like flight freezing yeah
there's Sparks happening I can't focus
and then um and I just kind of like
started crying like it just it just
started coming out of me and just
feeling like I
I I honestly I go well it's just I can't
have any contact with them I just can't
do it it's just too excruciating or then
I'll go why can't I just have a kind of
a sense of humor about it why can't I
just walk into these situations and just
kind of go it's literally six hours with
my family on Christmas like whatever
just and yet it's not yes exactly is
your partner good at that because Val is
the best okay and they're tied for first
because Val is like Pete
stop it yeah we almost had a little
funeral for we bought this little coffin
we never did it but we were going to
fill it with all these hopes yeah the
things you I know we're dead we're dead
let's not even release this we're dead
you and I are dead
put it on our Wikipedia page we died
today at the same time because it's too
much yes but we she wanted to like a
ritual to help me lit like watch it burn
up and just be like it just is what it
is okay yeah but even as you're saying
this I ha this gets a big laugh when I
say it on stage two and it's one of
those things that I didn't even know was
funny but one of my cousins said to me
was like
but you know you get married but I'm
doing my dad's voice it wasn't my dad
but it is kind of something he would say
but he goes but your mom's always your
number one girl and I was like
I'm I'm feeling it right now like acid
rain on me where even though I can have
these boundaries even though yeah it's a
it's a win it's not a win I'm fully
comfortable to be like we're gonna stay
home I just saw you in October I'm gonna
take a break yes but you hear the guilt
I'm even saying like I saw you
which none of us enjoyed so check check
check
[Music]
sorry I have to say that to you the
insanity of my family is not enjoying a
hang and during the Hang you're not
enjoying your planning the next one oh
my God
kills me even okay even with even just
like just friends when you're out of
dinner and they're like already setting
the next one two months from now I
thought like that's why we just did this
so we don't have to see
a long time
you feel this way too yes you keep
waiting yes for 13 12 year old people to
show up with this 43 year old therapized
grump keeps showing up and saying things
like I'm not responsible for your
happiness mom this isn't a good hang
I said to my very casually she was
actually doing a really good job because
she's she's she is a learning person and
I'm watching her adapt and stopping
herself from playing some of the old
games that she used to play so she
actually is improving that's a that's
incredible it is and Val was the one I
mean truly that feel I feel like that is
so rare it is rare So credit where
credit's due and I and
I really hope this isn't that a guild I
really love her and there's like a
desire for this connection and yet
I had somebody show up in my life it was
a friend and was like I just miss us we
hadn't talked in 20 years yeah yeah I
was like I needed Val to put it together
but she was like they miss who you
worded them 20 years ago oh my God and
they don't know and this friend was even
like I don't even know your work I
didn't watch crashing I didn't I don't
want your special I don't lose your
podcast because I don't want you to
change doesn't that sound like something
your mom would say yes right I mean it's
the same sort of codependent yes be
you're here to support this
puke City I I uh I had a friend recently
text me
um
it was a sort of late night text and she
said I just want you to know I'm always
I'm always here for you uh like I I just
I love you forever and I'm always here
for you and I wish my reaction had been
like oh that's so thoughtful like that's
really nice my first I was like okay
she's on her period because I know she
texts when she's sad like late night and
so I kind of I discount that for
honestly for myself and really I just
always feel like that's a different
that's a different thing I know we're
not supposed to do that but I just feel
that no I know by the way we all have
hormonal things the fact that there's a
predictable one is just it doesn't make
women different from men yeah we're all
having that but there is a predictable
one yes like I know I'm gonna have I'm
gonna want to like quit my career every
time I'm on my period it just happens
every single time Val and I just had a
little uh we're very sweet but we had a
dust up and she was like I'm sorry I'm
on my period And I was like and I was
like and I must be on whatever my boy
I'm not trying to be funny but like a
boy I really overreacted too so we're
all doing it yeah yeah just do it on the
schedule for sure and not always not
every not every period is that way right
unless you're me and then every single
time like it must work she said that not
crazy don't cancel it menstruation
cancellation Pete Holmes is going down
in flames after Jeannette McCurdy who
I'm reading now on the prompter is glad
her mom died uh Pete Holmes claimed that
all women get emotional and said what
used to be funny in the 90s Papa my doll
remember that that was like a thing it's
a
it's of love being able to just write
off something as being on my period it
makes me feel like less accountable for
it it's so funny that it's being a girl
I don't know why why
I say this too much but it's one of the
greatest Revelations of my 40s we are
blocks of tofu hormones go through that
tofu yeah we behave in accordance to
them yeah and then we call it our
personality all it was was chemicals we
all know this when you don't eat I don't
know if there's got to be a hormonal
yeah you eating your hormones too for
sure
I noticed it uh if you exercise with
weights my testosterone goes up I become
a lot like quicker to anger and this is
like road rage uh gym rage I told that
one I used to run a lot and I felt like
oh I can't run because it makes me so
much more hot tempered and and yeah
because you're coursing with all these
like you know go kill a lion hormone
sure sure so I can't say it enough
because it leads to self-forgiveness you
know what I mean it also leads to like
not taking anything too seriously yeah
sure sure sometimes like I was saying my
heart was open because I said to my dad
let's go on a road trip that was just a
different hormone I'm not saying there
isn't an us that's doing stuff sure but
boy it we're us we're a sailboat and
every Breeze is a hormone definitely and
everybody nobody's immune to that yeah
right
um I forgot what I was who cares we'll
find it
um the worst host who cares as long as I
get to make my hormones point I was
saying you were saying if you have your
period period oh your friend Texas oh my
friend text me and I wanted my thank you
um I wanted to remember I wanted to feel
there was there were a couple layers my
first instinct I was like irritated
honestly that that um that this person
had texted from this place because I
felt okay this person knew we had a very
codependent relationship this person
nobody at a time when I
um really was struggling a lot and um
and this person I my thought as to why
we became Less close was I I think I was
such we were codependent it was
unhealthy but also I think this person
um was a fixer in a lot of ways and and
really I mean was so incredibly kind and
helpful to me in so many ways but there
be there came a certain point where I
felt like I needed to
um take care of myself and do that for
myself and I couldn't rely so much on
this person and I kind of had recognized
the unhealthy Dynamic and then I pulled
away and then that became like
oh okay we can't exist unless we're in
that very specific Dynamic where it's
like me being needy me needing help me
struggling and you feeling like you're
the Savior and we can't get past that
and that was
it was difficult it was uncomfortable
um but then this text just hit me as
irritating because I thought like what
do you mean I'm here if you ever need
anything that immediately puts me lower
makes me feel like you know what I'm
saying oh yeah like I completely let's
fire up the old engine yes yes because I
like who I am when you're that yes and
I'm gonna ask you to be that because I
miss being that and you're like what
like when people point out that helping
can be uh let's put it this way on the
Enneagram the two is the helper and and
the problem that the or the the shadow
of the two is that you like want you
want people to appreciate you you also
want people to not appreciate you
anything that you can do to validate the
fact that either you're better than
everybody because you're helping or
you're better than everybody because
you're helping like both are the same
yes yeah I I completely agree with that
and and in this in mind I think the
person was asking me to help them and
what's weird is there was a time in my
life where I was really
hadn't realized who I was and therefore
this is going to sound really
pretentious but like there's a time in
my life where I was just more of an
idiot and leaned into being an idiot
because being an idiot made you kind of
fun sure sure like if you were just kind
of a doofus you know and then this
person was like be that doofus for me I
remember that doofus and I was like that
was 20 years ago and I've yeah again
this is the height of this is literally
pretentious but it's like it's been a
lot of therapy a lot of books a lot of
learning a lot of growing yeah and I
don't wanna
I even looked back and I was like I was
putting it on to merge with you or to
mirror right you right I was lowering
that's what I think a lot of people are
doing lowering to a level because they
People Like Us sensitive people can tell
that's what's being asked and now we're
back to our families lower your age
lower your why is it so I've thought a
lot about this recently why is it so
difficult to maintain
the growth from what from therapy or
books or whatever it's been or aging or
perspective whatever why is it so
difficult to maintain that in certain
environments like why and around certain
people why can't because because
I wish it would were possible to just
kind of maintain those relationships I I
I I don't know how to do that to just be
the person I am now and I feel like I
immediately revert I start literally
talking to my voice feels different
coming out of my body they do it's like
do you oh Falcon Tom on the phone with
my mom oh my God yeah yeah yeah of
course yeah and again as a parent I'm
like Leela you can't have oh you can't
have Dad voice we're not doing that and
I know that's good maybe be a thing but
you know what it is one of the most
beautiful lines and it was brutal in
your book is the the vibe in your house
was like a held breath right yeah I
think I'm getting that right yeah uh I I
think I am it's so funny anytime
somebody quotes it I'm always like oh
God like I don't know why yeah I think
held breath is feels what it feels like
um
I've been I I don't know it feels like a
so dramatic like just hearing that sound
so dramatic and I'm like I didn't mean
it remember in the movie held breath
like it sounds so like what was it okay
okay in my book I talk about my parents
fighting and I said me and my brother
Frozen in his room like dogs waiting for
fireworks to end
I mean as you say it yeah that'll give
me the same feeling where I'm like but
you know what remember an adaptation did
you see adaptation yeah actually so kind
of like a couple years ago pretty
recently for the first time okay it's
great it's one of my faves yeah and the
guy playing Robert McKee the story guy
is like and uh Nick Cage who's playing
Charlie Kaufman asks what about a story
where nothing really happens so you're
saying you feel too dramatic yeah and he
goes what about a story where nothing
much really happens and he goes nothing
happens it's the guy from succession he
goes things happen
life is dramatic a friend dies on the
steps of a church is his example
which makes me laugh
every time it's so specific yeah a
friend dies of the steps of a church
I'm getting the Impressions coming in
better but you know what I'm saying so
what you're saying is it's too dramatic
and that's embarrassing yeah life's
[__] dramatic yeah the kids waiting
for parents to stop fighting and in your
house yeah so this all leads to what I
like about a held breath is it's so
I'm doing it it's like it's so um
precarious you don't want to let it out
you don't want to let Moreno you want to
just hold it but you're going to shake
and meaning
isn't it that there's no room like one
of the the qualities of spirituality
that I like that I I think it helps
cultivate a spaciousness and when when
when you feel spacious there's room it's
what I'm trying to do with you there's
room for Jeanette to be who Jeanette is
today you know what I mean and you're
doing that for me I feel that I you did
this podcast I don't know seven years
ago so it's like we can be different it
can be different yeah that's great but
again
it seems to be a common phenomenon so
maybe we can say by no fault of their
own but when we go home
there's no spaciousness there's so you
have to I've always said it's like they
hand you your lines my question for you
though is do you think they feel that
way do you think my dad is like thank
God Peter left I can finally I don't
think he does I don't think he does you
know yeah I I I I I I I don't and it it
it's
disappointing because I I'm
I really could just be completely
undermining them but my thought is like
I don't think they do the kind of they
don't they don't do the digging they
don't they don't it's just yeah I
literally and and yeah literally I I
wonder are they do they just go home
that was a fun that was that was fine we
got through that was good like what is
their reaction I'm sitting there feeling
like my soul's like being sucked from my
body and are they just like that was a
good time like I don't know I don't know
that's that goes back to my most heart
my most heartbreaking point is when
things just aren't good
you can only disrupt something that is
good like our our house is a happy house
yeah and then comes this other element
and it [__] everything up yeah like it
really does are they going home and
going like that was weird
or are they just like right I think
they're in like a a like kind of a stuck
State and you you move that state around
but it doesn't it doesn't change like
we've tried yeah yeah you and I have
tried our our whole lives to kind of one
you know one of my sister-in-laws I
think she we've we we're less close than
we used to be I've known her since I was
six years old she and my brother were
high school sweethearts and they've been
together for so long
um but there there was definitely a
shift in my 20s where I realized okay I
think I just don't think like I I feel
like I'm being really fake to keep this
relationship going at the same at the
same Pace that it's going and to be as
kind of intertwined with this person as
I am and and
um and I think that's totally normal you
know it's what happens in your 20s I I
think
um but but I I kind of started creating
distance there and I know she has picked
up on it I you know I can feel the
tension God but then I don't I also
don't want to bring it up because I know
that that's going to bring to closeness
no I think it'll make us closer
so I'm like [__] this is
like yeah I know she feels it I feel
that if I I could bring it up or or I
mean she could also have brought it up
any number of times but neither of us do
and I know I'm not doing it because I
think that it will make us closer you
actually just helped me find a different
Truth for me tell me because my mom
always because a Pity sweetie you're
tolerating me
oh my God and she's like I don't want to
be tolerated and I'm like that's like
yeah I I am because right it's too
she wants that little boy
sit on her lap yeah yeah sure kiss her
yeah give her smooches and and and also
just completely merge like there's so
much merging yes in fact the whole thing
is merging you didn't like acting your
mom's like you love acts yes yes I love
acting and like all of this suppression
right and when you grow up that doesn't
work that dog won't Hunt is that the
expression that dog won't hunt yeah it
doesn't hunt anymore it you know it you
maybe thought I don't know why anyone
like this
I I saw a on my YouTube recommended like
Kim Cattrall I think Kim Cattrall from
Sex and the City is that right
um some sort of speech for like a women
in power event or something she's like
this is what happens when you go where
you're celebrated and not where you're
tolerated that totally yeah yeah
um it just makes me think of I I I don't
know I've thought about that on a couple
occasions I'm not like super familiar
with Kim Cattrall's work but just that
yeah that has I don't know it's there's
something there's something to it I um
yeah I I I know your mom died
what a dumb thing to say I just wondered
did that give closure let's actually get
to that question we have to we do
mid-rolls now we weren't doing them
seven years ago we do minerals but when
we come back I want to talk about if you
got closure from that or if it's just
the same looming presence yeah because
I've heard therapists go both ways yeah
um so we'll be right back in literally
two minutes and we'll and we'll keep
going on this great conversation
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at next Evo and I know we've talked a
lot about CBD but next Evo has
absolutely cracked the code meaning this
is CBD for people who have tried CBD in
the past and just weren't that into it
because why first of all this is these
are my words I don't know how they did
it with science they did it with science
they found a way to get the CBD into
your system really quickly so you can
tell how it feels get your dose just
right and get the effect just dialed in
perfectly and I'm holding right here the
CBD uh the stress CBD complex which
mixes CBD in a gummy with ashwagandha
ashwagandha we talk a lot about
adaptogens on this podcast it's because
they've absolutely changed my life
something about the blend of ashwagandha
and CBD together this is absolutely been
my secret weapon against stress but also
not just to like relax or like loaf out
on the couch but if I'm trying to work
and I'm just a little bit too worked up
or a little bit too tense to get into
the a place where I can just answer
emails or sit down with a document that
I have to work on I take one of these
and like I'm saying 10 minutes later you
just you ease into it and you're able to
work you're able to focus you're able to
relax and go on a date or enjoy a movie
something at the end of the day that can
help take the edge off for sure but also
something in the morning that can help
you ease into the things that you have
to do because honestly I'm a sensitive
person I get overwhelmed easily I know a
lot of us do and the stress CBD complex
has been a huge huge help for me the new
year is obviously a fresh opportunity to
achieve your full potential but you
can't be your best if you're stressed so
if you've tried if you've tried the
stress CBD complex like I have you'll
see it's a total Game Changer helping
you get into that flow State and I
didn't know it was possible to have CBD
get into you this quickly usually it's
kind of like I don't know did I take it
is it here this there's no doubt it's
here and you can dial it in just right
uh yes it's just CBD complex has both
smart sorb smart sword meaning it
absorbs smartly smartsorb CBD and a
patented whole plant ashwagandha
clinically proven to reduce stress by up
to 70 and improve concentration by 50
next Evo uses that it's over 30 times
better absorption in the first 30
minutes so don't just use any CBD brand
most CBD products on the market have
only two to ten percent absorption two
to ten percent absorption so at least 90
is actually wasted it's simple if it's
not absorbed it can't help you and next
Evo has cracked the code it's different
it delivers four times better overall
CBD absorption and has been proven in
multiple clinical studies and mixed with
that ashwagandha it's an absolute Game
Changer so make CBD a part of your full
potential with next Evo Naturals go to
next evo.com podcast and use promo code
weird to get 20 off your first order of
40 or more that's twenty percent off 40
bucks or more at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash podcast promo
code weird I know that by heart because
I use my own promo code to order refills
on this and I'm just fully subscribed at
this point next up oh I gotta get it
hold the phone what is this this is a
metal poster this is this is the not
feeling it chicken and this is available
on disk plate uh display.com Slash Pete
homes and we have five different designs
ready to purchase one of them of course
is the not feeling it chicken so if you
love I'm not feeling it as much as I do
and you want something substantial not
just a piece of paper hanging on your
wall peeling off on one corner looking
like crap get yourself a one of a kind
metal poster designed to capture your
unique passions display created a 21st
century canvas as you can see is dirty
magnet mounted and durable enough to
withstand a lifetime of intense sharing
but start starting is only half the fun
you can even customize collect and
rearrange them at will displace display
excuse me disklate has both branded and
artistic artwork they have over 1
million designs available for everyone
including Marvel DC Star Wars Netflix
NASA South Park games movies you can
find something for everyone anything
that they're passionate about I
guarantee you'll find some version of it
on display and you'll find it in this
permanent awesome heavy badass looking
way each product is high quality design
printed on metal in Europe and hand
signed by their master of production
display creates a unique safe magnet
mounting system that only takes 20
seconds you don't have to drill into
your walls all you do is wipe off your
wall with a cleaning wipe stick on a
protective Leaf Place a magnet and put
the disc plate on your wall
it's that easy this plate delivers its
products worldwide in only 45 business
days it's a perfect alternative for
standard paper posters that often get
damaged and don't look that great and it
doesn't leave marks on the wall it's
incredible they also uh they're also
eco-friendly for every design sold they
are planting a tree so right now display
is having the biggest discount ever
that's one to two disc plates you get 20
off three or more you get 30 off like I
said there's five heat homes display
it's at display.com Pete homes use the
link in the description go to
display.com slash Pete homes
d-i-s-p-l-a-t-e.com slash Pete homes and
use code weird at the checkout display
collect your passions all right
everybody let's get back to the second
half of Jeanette McCurdy
and we're back
um what I was going to say like the
longer version of the couch is it really
like yeah it's really good it really is
I'm glad you like it yeah I've had
people really not like it why what's a
good deep seated okay a lot of people
just slump in it I'm for sure slumping
but I love that I love feeling like you
just kind of become like but you're the
only one that went crossy legged that's
what you're supposed to do I tell
everybody most people Chris's strategist
did it and he was great but he's he sat
like Pinocchio on the edge of a stool
how do you the whole time he was just
like okay he's kind of to the side it
was like we were in a car today very
intimate we are this is what it's
supposed to be locked off sleepover
style you're the only one that gets this
judging
you're the only one and before we get to
my question I won't forget the question
what is your favorite candy my favorite
candy is Sour Patch Kids
looking great choice it's a good choice
right
Jesus Christ I remember being scared of
Sally Patch Kids why because they're
sour I don't want that I don't want a
nine volt battery with my popcorn I love
this art like the warheads and the you
know the anything that like makes your
tongue lose feeling after you've had it
I wish I had I bought I have something
called grenades gum which is the
strongest gum I like to say it's the
strongest gum in the world I don't know
if that's true but it's like Japanese
stronger okay like novelty Japanese sure
for sure and I absolutely love it it's
like are you an addict yeah I would say
definitely that's my yeah I didn't mean
to jump right there no sure but a lot of
people like us yeah that I like I got
over it I now love sour if there's
something I can eat that'll like clear
my sinuses that's what grenades do you
like jalapenos I'll eat a jalapeno oh
see I have a theory that anybody who's
an addict loves jalapenos or really just
anything that has a really really yeah
like intense oh yeah there's something
about mine is wasabi wasabi peas okay
great I'll eat those and I want the
painful one yes I don't give me the most
intense give me the [__] gift I want
tears in my eyes I regret this because
um Richard Rohr who writes a lot about
addiction
who I love he said that what addicts are
looking for is the feeling of being
alive the reason I like that is it
humanizes us it's not just like just
pure victim like they just can't stop
right it's actually like there's
actually something it's a
misappropriation of a beautiful urge and
and there's even a misappropriation of
like the Ghost of Christmas present in
the Muppet uh Muppet
Christmas movie yeah the retelling of of
um The Charles Dickens ones yeah yeah
sure Michael kind
um I'm sort of I can be like the Ghost
of Christmas present where I'm like more
more Wasabi yeah more more spicy more
feeling yes but then that can go all
these dark ways but
um
what was I saying oh so the feeling of
being alive I when you're burning up
from a Wasabi there's no question that
you exist yes you know what I mean oh my
God I'm here yeah yeah yes [__] here
I'm the guy that's burning up with
what's up yeah you relate to that yeah
and Richard war that sounds familiar
that I'm obsessed with I absolutely love
him he wrote falling upward I think is
his biggest book okay no I haven't read
it but his name sounds familiar maybe
I've seen a TED talk or something maybe
yeah he has a lot of crossover because
he's one of those I hate that this that
you have to like
like let spiritual people have to be
like you know he's he loves everyone
he's not he doesn't judge people he
doesn't uh believe in Hal all of these
so he's just talking about the present
moment he's just talking about
accepting your acceptedness I think I
think that's actually one of his lines
accepting your that you are accepted see
that's a little that's a reach for me
that's like okay let me think did I lose
you accepting that you're accepted yeah
he would say that the job of being a
human is to accept that you're accepted
because by yourself by by the universe
you could say we don't have to say God
you can just say that you are a
dignified member of reality how do you
feel about it is do you label the
universe what do you what do I use yeah
I have no problem with God but that's me
neither I well here's my thought I I for
a while I well from growing up religious
I was so sort of like absolutely no hard
no on anything religious no God no
whatever and then I kind of was dipping
my toe back in into spirituality and
started calling it The Universe and then
I felt like well if I'm gonna call it
the universe like why not just call it
God that felt kind of I don't know it
just it feels I think it's empowering
yes yes yes because if you don't call it
God talk about yes handing your
victimhood that's the first thing we
said
but if you don't you're going look and
this is a fine way to feel yeah
but for me getting back to a place where
I could say God I can even throw out a
Jesus a sweet baby Jesus there you go
there you go I can throw out a sweet
baby cheese
um for me yeah I sometimes Val and I do
the Friday podcast and I'll catch myself
saying the Holy Spirit or something and
I'm like you gotta watch it because some
people hate this language so much but it
just like comes out of it yeah I know I
want to talk about that with you because
the holy the Holy Ghost is different in
the Latter-Day Saint tradition a little
bit what is the Holy Spirit what is the
same thing oh okay yeah yeah Holy Spirit
Holy Ghost okay but the communique the
open communication we'd love to talk
about that or we can just tease that
that's in the book it's very interesting
but to me the yes ending of the
victimhood is saying like this is so
[__] and twisted for me and ruined for
me I can't even say it or you go like no
I'm going to start saying and I'm going
to retrain that Groove and and reclaim
it yeah take back the night oh my God
right yep oh 100 yeah that that's been
meaningful for me even though I
understand if somebody doesn't want to
say it so accepting that you're accepted
I I've studied a lot of spiritual
different practices yeah and I I was
thinking about this on the Right End
actually
I was thinking they all sort of come
down to dropping your guilt dropping
your shame I'm not talking about
mainstream Christianity they would love
you to keep your oh yeah yes and the
Mormon church as well like a lot of
churches can have that going on for sure
I say that based on the Mormons that I
knew that would tie their wrists so bad
at night so that's not exactly going
like God loves you no matter what relax
go have a good jerk in the bathroom hey
Elder go have a big jerk in the bathroom
because you obsessing about it is way
worse than just blasting one out getting
on with your mission buddy this is
there's some there's some Mormon
missionary in in Venezuela listening and
he's like he's right
but says Doc Martens takes them off with
the yellow colored in and just blasts
out oh God
I've offended myself
accepting that you're accepted dropping
shame dropping guilt and realizing that
this thing that we call God is is inside
of you and and and everywhere meaning
not in the sky yes and if if God which
we can all agree is perfect Oneness
perfect Holiness all these things that
don't mean anything yeah yeah and it's
inside of you you therefore are also
holy or good or by holy I mean like
whole and you've sort of Forgotten and
peace or salvation or conversion or
Enlightenment is going like if I'm a
piece of God and God is perfect then I
am perfect because I can't be the I'm
not sullying it like it can't be solid
yeah yeah so I'm just telling myself a
story of guilt when I could just drop
that wake up to reality wake up to
perfect Oneness that that's that's what
I would say a lot of them are our point
and you mentioned both guilt and shame
yeah the the the
twisty uh chocolate vanilla ice cream
cone of shame and guilt what is your
I I've gotten so mixed up in guilt and
shame I
typically think of guilt as helpful I
think if guilt is like okay I need to
like
apologize correct something do you wanna
if you like being corrected you're gonna
love this okay yeah
no 100 JK
um I think just the language I would use
is the difference between guilt and
remorse ah yes yeah yeah yes totally
remorse is good totally so so guilt and
shame are is it according to Richard
Rohr or this is what kind of
generalization I'm saying a lot of them
are interesting like go easy on yourself
yes yeah I find language like some
people find this gaslighting like Val
does not like this type of language but
thinking of reality as a dream or or
just play my daughter's name is Lila it
means play yeah or dance of Life yeah
meaning
it is what we're perceiving yeah but not
just somewhere else
behind this is a perfect loving Oneness
like here and now it's yeah it's here
yeah and we've our job is to remove the
impediments to perceiving it and you
know how you do that it's by loving each
other forgiving each other and forgiving
yourself and forgiving reality yes so
it's all of this stuff that nobody in
their right mind really wants to do
again not sure [__] on your mom but she
loved the victimhood yes she loved guilt
and she loved to blame and everything
was like I'm saying this because I
relate yeah I do this too yeah
everything else is the problem and
everyone else is the person yes yes yes
and like that's a nice thing to do with
your guilt is Project it out and go this
casting agent won't book Jeanette yeah
[__] you yeah sweetheart I I mean it
like really sweet sweet heart sweetheart
not like a Don Draper cigarette cocktail
waitress but like sweetheart yeah [__]
like let's just go easy on ourselves
yeah that's what we're doing yeah we're
scapegoating when really it's easier
said than done but like just relax into
the sizzling champagne bubble bath
right here you know I didn't realize the
thing about self-fergent it always felt
to me like that was such a like it was
you know lazy or
um you know I I have I I feel such a
need to like prove myself even to myself
that the idea of like it just felt like
going easy on myself letting myself go I
kind of feared what was on the other
side of self-forgiveness but I really
did I feel you know because you vanish
yes exactly exactly what's the opposite
of Wasabi exactly you're not exactly or
angry or right
God I love that right what oh yeah where
do you go yes exactly exactly what the
word for that is is Mercy father Greg
Boyle did this podcast and he was like I
don't like forgiveness because
forgiveness acknowledges that something
bad happens something wrong happened
Mercy is just um
it's always there it doesn't think about
it well Jeanette didn't mean to hurt my
feelings right she's probably having a
bad day that's like [__] cheap Dollar
Store forgiveness but Mercy is like
completely irrational keeping completely
illogical and does not
perpetuate or affirm Your Existence
which which makes it so scary right it's
better to be like you know [__] you
because that's a Wasabi pea I wonder why
too like Mercy I immediately think more
religious than for even forgiven for a
while I think there I also was was
averse but because of it being so
religiously
um but then now it's like okay Mercy
seems more religious than forgiveness
why does something like I immediately
felt myself be kind of defensive toward
Mercy when you just said we're talking
about it right there I felt myself like
oh I don't know I can kind of like Get
on Board I get it with that like I
completely get it you know I don't know
but I think Mercy is offensive to most
people if we're being honest because
Mercy says nothing happened and if
nothing happened then like what this
doesn't matter right that [__]
or this mother or that piece I'm right
and they deserve hell and I deserve
heaven and it goes now drop it all in
the acid of of mercy and we go like we
don't want a god with Mercy we want a
God that decides with us and and
condemns our enemies yeah right it's
another bad parent we want a special
relationship with our secret God and
everybody else gets [__]
and I say that with again I'm trying to
say that with compassion because I used
to be one of those people sure sure it
feels good yeah yeah it's more
comfortable it's more yeah I'm gonna
throw you another weird one yeah even if
God's mad at you if you think you're a
wicked little boy yeah girl that's good
because at least he knows who you are
Val and I were just talking about this
which is also very dualistic and it's
also not Mercy it's not even forgiveness
a giraffe but you love it because it's
another Wasabi P you upset the president
of the [__] Cosmos and he's coming
for you that feels good too you never
occurred to me that you might your
behavior might actually be unconsciously
seeking things that you know quote
unquote No God won't like because at
least then Wasabi P you exist because
you're walking around with that heavy
lead coat you wear at the dentist the
shame yeah guilt and you're it and
you're Wicked and he's gonna kick your
ass or burn you up but at least he's
affirming Jeanette McCurdy exists her
behavior mattered right Mercy sucks we
hate Mercy the mercy that just goes like
come on in who wants to go to a country
club where everyone can get in there's
okay I I have concern how do you stay
grounded well spiritual practice is big
for you is that is it seems like it's so
it's how do you stay grounded
big time put my Twitter handle at the
bottom big time
[Laughter]
I am just having a laugh that a man who
sells his ego in segments for his job is
also like love the Lord I do but it's
funny too it's both it can be both
Big Time spiritual have you read my
Wikipedia page Holmes is interested in
spirituality's of all varieties humility
Mercy he's it says he's more into Mercy
than forgiveness with the one and the
references of this podcast
what a silly silly thing we're doing
[Laughter]
extreme
oh my god oh gosh okay Edison I I
[Laughter]
oh my gosh I I love therapy it has
helped me to be a functioning person
um in a in a you know and a healthy
person but I do feel
I guess I feel concerned that I just
becoming too therapized becoming too
spiritual that I get lost in which is I
know kind of the the the the point is to
Lose Yourself and all and like you know
whatever
um but
I
like there's some there's some times
when if a therapist's telling me
something and they're kind of like
neutralizing my thinking where it's just
it makes me want to throw something like
it's just like that's so [__] neutral
yeah that's not like their hat like if
you don't if you don't stand for
something for you'll fall for anything
like that it just feels like what is
where like I want them and I I the the I
work with therapists now who really will
tell me how she feels and what her kind
of
judgment is about the thing or where
she's like oh you know what I don't
think this is like she just tells me
where she stands and I find it so
helpful because I think where do you you
can't everything's not just like well
it's neither here nor there it could be
this or it could be I know it could be
this or it could be that I'm here to
figure out whether it's this or that
yeah I by the way we've just stepped
into another one of my favorite and this
is what Val is so good yes you need Val
you can't just have Pete you need Val to
meaning there's different altitudes and
if you want to come yeah put that out
please okay my Pete home show pillows I
love humility
I just love Vanishing into the void of
God's love watch Pete home show clips on
YouTube be sure to subscribe and make
sure alerts are on
100 JK in fact unsubscribe I'm just
kidding I don't know where to what I'm
doing
there's just different altitudes and I
think this is one of the tricky things
different altitudes to fly out yeah so
here's your issue yes and we can fly way
up here I feel like Jeanette just
dissolve into the champagne hot tub of
God's love [__] [__] off right yeah
because sometimes you just the most
loving thing to do which again
isn't just for its own sake it's like by
me loving and when I say forgiving I
don't mean looking the other way on an
error but just meeting you where you are
not going like well Jeanette should
realize that God's love is right here
and why she [__] that forgiveness might
actually just be like Jesus Christ yeah
you shouldn't have to go I just had to
go to traffic school to traffic school
or whatever it is like sometimes you
need that yeah yeah but like that
spiritual bypassing or as I think you
were saying
being ungrounded yeah untethered feet
off the ground sometimes can be the
least helpful thing in fact Val has to
remind me all the time that she's like
don't be too romdas be Richard because
Richard Rohr is very on the earth and
very loving and ramdas would be like
it's all illusion baby yeah yeah not
helpful right now and he would say the
same I'm gonna look up uh Richard Moore
you will love Richard Wright yeah if
you're okay with the sweet G's a little
Mentor every every five pages you might
he might talk about oh it's sweet juice
okay that's a lot is it a lot every five
pages yeah but the pages are huge okay
they're like beaches okay you have to go
like
oh man there's like a whole there's like
it's 5 10 page book
um the naked now is a good one are you
do you like Eckhart Tolle and stuff
um I did I did The Power of Now and I
did the what the follow-up the new Earth
yes yes they're both kind of a while ago
and I really liked them but I read them
and I was when I was sort of falling in
love into a really into a very addictive
uh relationship and I think I was just
kind of high on that and like reading
them from that place like oh my God
everything's a mate like it was the most
so funny yeah it was it was it was I was
I was 21 and it was it was intense yeah
I I was gonna say is it this one you're
like a really toxic like unhealthy
codependent relationship you mean the
one you know I relate so hard to what
you're saying because the last time I
I've read or listened to those books
dozens of times and the last time was
when I was starring in a multicam sitcom
which as you know super fun it's a great
schedule I know yours was complex but
the schedule schedule yeah for sure for
sure at Old homes they was so high on
life that it was bleeding into his
interpretation of spiritual things and
that's like I can get kind of
embarrassed I'm like yeah you were the
star of your own show of course you
could walk around being like it's all
one man it's all one right right but I
have to do traffic school and I'm like
maybe Duality is real you know because
this website's really riding my ass
than traffic school it was the I thought
it might be fun it was the most boring
thing I haven't been it's well it was
online okay just reading stuff yeah
which one of the questions was like
which of the following is a two-point
violation how is that helpful what is
this for what I got I just got pulled
over okay speaking of which do you have
that because I have that from my mom the
story of you and your dad getting the
Smoothie yeah and then you come home and
your mom is like waiting for you yeah
the sound of her keys like if I heard
her keys to this day I could tell you
that from any other set of keys it's
like yeah so distinct yeah brutal yeah
does has that this stays on the
spiritual thing do you still have a hard
time accepting an image of God that
isn't waiting for you with keys because
that stuff bleeds into
can bleed into our perception of our
higher power you know I I I try not to I
try to think of
God as there's still an element of
needing to perform for him of needing to
like achieve for him or feeling like
well if I do this then good things will
happen and I definitely noticed I had a
bit more I had a bit of a like
Resurgence of OCD kind of a couple weeks
into the book coming out and with it it
you know doing so and I wanted it to
keep doing well so I thought oh if I
keep if like my ritualistic behavior was
kind of just clicking into gear again
right if I keep everything if I keep
control over all these things then I
then I'll the success will continue and
it was yeah I I I've definitely had to
pay extra attention to that yeah you
know for the first couple months I
relate hard really somebody just this
last week Val and I had a nice chat
about this on we made it weird but oh no
it didn't come up we meant to somebody
texted me and they were like I want a a
dear friend of mine yeah she's like I
really want to break into writing and
I'm like why do I hate this so much and
I actually we uncovered it we talked
about it for quite a while not meaning
the person or the ask sure sure I'm just
like why do I hate trying to find an
answer to this question and I was like I
think it dropped brings into
my awareness something I don't want to
look at which is the randomness of of
success sure sure so when you're
ritualizing oh God your book success oh
it's from a fear of the same thing right
I 100 want to believe it's because it's
this great work of art and it's all the
writing or whatever your ritual was how
is that different from me being like
it's stick-to-itiveness or whatever the
[__] you know what I mean yeah we're
talking about I was like there's a lot
of people yeah very talented because I'm
like oh they didn't make it but they
weren't out every night a lot of them
were they didn't they didn't make it by
the way we're putting make it in quotes
but they didn't write uh spec script A
lot of them did like there's this like X
Factor element of unfair cold
it's like
it's Plinko on The Price is Right things
are just and you don't want to look at
it and when someone says how do you
become a writer and you're like well in
you asking me it's it's really making me
realize that there you could call it
luck you could call it fate you could
call it good fortune these are all
synonymous but like
there's un there's right time right
place stuff and that's scary yeah
meaning I'm not OCD but I have
I'll catch myself being like don't think
that way because that's not a and the
universe will will see you for who you
are and we'll turn off the faucet yes
right yep that's again I'm just trying
to relate to you totally that's not
clinical OCD but it is magical thinking
yes and everybody I'm not saying
everybody has that I can't speak for
everybody I have that yeah yeah yeah so
your book was doing well what was how
did it manifest or is that a two persons
no no no so I I mean this is maybe the
the scariest of all because I hadn't I
I'm sort of I need to purge things often
because my mom was a hoarder and so I
feel like oh I want to keep my space
very clean but I was like holding on to
um shampoo and conditioner that I had
finished because I was like oh well that
was the shampoo I was using when it
debuted at number one and I wanted to
stay at number one and it was number one
shampoo so it literally and and then
there was a part of me that was like
almost it would flirt with the idea of
relief at it not being at number one
because I thought well then I don't have
to uphold the rituals as soon as it's
not number one I don't have to keep
doing this but then of course it's like
well it's on the times list still so now
I'm just going to do it till it's off
time
like but I I mean I still have yeah I
have like a hand cream jar that was an
empty hand cream that's still in my
cupboard I have a shampoo and
conditioner
um and then like I Twirl in the bathroom
like I twirl around myself which is good
yeah exactly it is called twirling I
just want to make sure yeah when you
said that I thought maybe a baton or
something no I just myself yeah this is
this isn't uh othering you I'm curious
could you refill the old bottle with new
shampoo
it's just interesting to me that like
what are interesting let's talk about it
interesting I think that would work that
would feel that would feel okay to me
yeah yeah that would be okay sometimes I
can really get in touch with how insane
it is that we throw things away and like
things that meant stuff to us I've had
that with skin like you ever get like a
a sunburn and you pull off your skin
you're like this was me and then you
throw it away
I know it's really gross yeah but it
happens yeah something that was you and
I'm like this just goes in the trash
yeah and it was a blister literally a
couple weeks ago but see oh thank you
for joining me I was ready I was ready
to get rid of it yeah but you know
there's there's grocer and other
examples but you're just sort of like
through we we have a friend whose kid I
think has OCD and one time they had a
very big meltdown because they they
threw something away I think they were
just at Disneyland they threw away a
bottle yes and it was like but where is
it yes and I was like
look it's tempting to scapegoat that
child and be like grow up but I'm also
like
I thought that as I was taking out the
trash last week I was like this is just
our family how many bags where is this
trash yes
and also how weird is it that it's like
razors that were touching your face and
grooming you and these bottles that were
like you're saying with you at the time
yeah totally it was in my shower like
your bottles it was there with you yeah
all this time and you just [__] throw
it away yeah and isn't it well you tell
me is it death anxiety too is there
something like a I'll be thrown away
that is that's what it is for me I think
they're right there's some element of
that
um and then yeah I think there's some
element of that yeah but what is it more
um just what you said it's a specialness
yeah yeah and feeling like I want things
to keep going well I really really want
things to keep going well and I want to
believe I have some control over that I
really want to believe that I have some
hand or some ability to keep that
happening
um
and yeah I don't I don't want to believe
it's random I don't want to believe
there's any element that's random or but
also with your mom again going to the
universe and and I'm really struck
sometimes when I'm like our parents
teach us
not what God actually is but how we
relate to God I think we can meaning
your mom was a was like a 50-sided
Rubik's Cube you know what I mean like
it seemed like you didn't know which one
you were going to get but like like me
it's different but similar
got very good at reading it when I was
reading a book I was like oh you'll
relate to like I could speak mom but no
one else could speak mom and I could
speak Dad out translate what Mom said
and I'd translate it to Dad yes yes and
then that translated my brother I was
like why am I the only one who can
[__] do that yes yes yes yes and the
line I said to my dad we still laugh
about it even though I'm like why are we
laughing about this is I was a little
kid like 10 and I looked at my dad and I
was like why don't you just do what mom
says because I thought I had figured out
the answer which is like if you want the
house to be calm just [__] do what
she says and as I got older I was like
because my dad is also a person with his
own needs and it was so I still kind of
wish he had maybe walked maybe middle
just the middle ground a couple
compromises here and there but um where
were we I do you have anything else
before I go back to the question well
I'm curious what that is what is that
what is that thing uh you have siblings
I have one brother yeah what is and he
he didn't speak the languages nobody
spoke John what is then what is that
what is that is it that you just want to
speak so you figure it out I think it is
to stop just fights I think to stop but
then why wouldn't other people like I
mean this truly like it baffles me um
why why
why are they trying to figure out yeah
yeah why aren't they everyone [__]
hates when shit's going crazy
I don't
see that's an Eckhart Tolle thing that's
in the power now I'm not trying to shame
you that you forgot it like no no no
don't you remember but he talks about
like how some relationships he talks
about her pain body and our pain body is
a collection of our past hurts our
psychology and all our attacking
memories yeah so it's like just the most
vulnerable yes when you like when Val
and I had that little dust up we both
were like I think we're in our pain
bodies it's just the language we use yes
because you feel sort of possessed
you're not thinking clearly yeah yeah I
feel I always feel like my brain's going
at a faster like it's just it can't
really focus it can't that's it yeah you
go like this would be solved if I would
just sit down take a breath but you
can't yeah you're just like I cannot
going too fast yeah yeah totally and
it's over some nonsense but um he
Eckhart Tolle says that some
relationships are just pain bodies who
get together to feed each other
not with like not feed each other
goodness yeah just feed each other yeah
like the meat from Tiger King yeah you
know disgusting pizzas yeah like you
just feed each other [__] because again
it's another type of Wasabi pea meaning
not everybody does want peace yeah and
it does go back to the spiritual thing
it's like
the first step to peace is admitting you
don't really want peace you actually
kind of like just a little even if it's
good stuff that's not very peaceful
because even when your book is doing
well you were like when does it end
that's another Wasabi Peak yes it's so
interesting I've been thinking too just
from Recently about sort of being having
the addict mindset having addictive
Tendencies and being just kind of
obsessive about things and and I'm in a
really good relationship now and I've
been we've been together for six years
um six and a half years but I
there's some times when I just feel like
the like it just is too boring for me
and we speak about this all the time
because it's he's he's very
Frank yeah
tell me about Frankie
you've just clickbait would you go into
your relationship with Franklin Muniz
and if you don't correct me we will
assume that it is Frankie
M and the m munas
sorry I didn't mean oh my God but we did
have a good lap so you're a good
relationship we're gonna lose it
yeah yes
um and uh and and he's okay with the
he's okay yeah he's okay with it and
he's um he's a steady Eddie he doesn't
have it he's very steady he's very
um he doesn't have that addictive like
he doesn't even relate you know I'll
I'll explain what it feels like for me
and he just doesn't have that that thing
that addictive kind of thing and um
there's some there's some part of me
that really just feels like God we know
with a stable relationship and I'm I'm
healthy and functioning now and there's
a part of me that crops up fairly often
like more often than I than I would like
for sure that's just like I just want to
[__] everything up I just want to do
something that's like rebellious and and
you know just just get that impulse you
know I wanna from oh yeah it's in the
master we're Joaquin Phoenix who
represents in my interpretation
represents the ego so it's the part and
he's talking to
um what is that guy's name Jesse plemons
yes yeah yeah who everybody loves we all
love
he's like get mad
hit me throw something
yeah he's like call me a [__] like it
won't tolerate just like okay and yeah
right which is peace yeah it can be used
and even as you're saying it and even
for all the good game I'm spitting about
like wanting surrender and wanting
forgiveness and stuff yeah
this is so healing to me this
conversation and we're not we're not
flying at the highest altitude sometimes
I I relate to what you're saying yes and
at the same time I'm like it sounds like
a good thing for for you because that's
what Val is for me
she is in therapy I used to say is when
we were dating I was like if there's any
problem it's that I will tire and she
knows this I'd go of the peppermint
Fountain like there's a fountain and I
just fill it up and it's like a clear
glass and it looks like a candy cane but
it's a glass of candy cane and I'm like
peppermint and if I ever get tired of
never-ending peppermint yeah thank God
here's something nice about my parents
whatever they did they instilled enough
like no you deserve to be happy you
deserve to be loved that I can go like
no you know what I I actually really
like somebody that loves me constantly
so much so that she talks about me in
her therapy and gives me little tips yes
at that might sound unloving but I take
it as quite loving yeah yeah so yeah so
yeah they they gave me that for sure but
so so and you've been almost seven years
almost seven years yeah which means
you've regenerated you've been
cellularly in six months you'll have
known each other completely different
people wow okay I mean it definitely
feels that way if we I I've changed so
much he's changed so much growing
together grow what's that growing
together yes yeah but then also just who
we are individually is has
um we've we've grown so much closer and
so much the that element I love and um
and I wouldn't trade that and also it's
it's cool to see how much we've I think
informed how we've each grown
individually but um in in big ways but
that we're we're more ourselves but just
yeah I it's really it's exactly the
phrase you want is more ourselves yeah
yeah the opposite of what we've been
talking about like imagine I've been in
relationships like this where you have
to get in character oh yeah yeah it's
it's the same wound playing out yeah but
if you found somebody where you can be
safe and be yourself I mean yeah I've
definitely had the in character ones
there was somebody I was with during
when I used to be on Vine that app that
really yeah I P Vine and we missed it
and the guy would say seem more like you
are on Vine like you beat like you know
do that more and I'm like
did he meet you on the app Vine I mean
the only way I would accept this is if
you met because you connected on Vine I
think he had seen I think I think he had
seen some of my Vine we didn't yeah we
didn't like meet the friend we met sort
of through social media yeah yes oh my
God can I say
who I we were talking about friends
don't miss us they miss who we were 20
years ago I don't miss the app Vine I
miss the guy that was making vines
just still kind of had had it in me I'd
make little like good night Vibes oh I
loved my Vine I was all about it oh I'm
very proud I wouldn't say I'm very proud
but you can type in because Val and I
did it yeah Pete Holmes Vine compilation
and I watched my old Vines and it sounds
like just like a exercise and narcissism
it was really just going like remember
well just like
silly yeah like I just seemed like I was
worried about less do you feel do you
feel that like do you feel that you're
worried about I do yeah like there's
part of my awareness that's like where's
Val where's Leela like just kind of like
in a loving way not a nervous way where
are they where are we at
meanders.com weird or the sponsors happy
stuff like that you know what I mean it
is I should pick a different one do you
feel yeah do you feel in in relationship
that you're that you I do that so often
I hate when I get stuck there of like
how are we compared to how we were
before how are we where are we gonna go
in the future like I have to try and try
and calm that part of myself become to
be present yeah because I really my
instinct is so often to not be present
and to be
um the list maker the the how many times
have we had sex this week okay is that
enough is that yeah okay you know and
you know
sometimes we need that yeah I mean like
in Valentine's relationship we we fill
in the blanks we're both kind of like
kind of soft and and gentle and then
there's different parts of each of us
that is rigid and here's part uh
internal family systems Parts work I'm
familiar with that I've never done it
though uh I've started it recently
really yeah I really I like it but Val's
recommended it before it's really I
think she's more familiar with it than I
am they just mentioned a thing of like
how sometimes you know you've got your
different parts and the the idea being
to sort of integrate them more but also
that sometimes it's okay to let a
certain part kind of take the reins if
that's what's needed yeah that's what
you said reminded me of of that and
letting the manager well you were
talking about you're freezing this yeah
I can help Val out of her Frozen this
and she can help me out of my frozen
nuts and what's beautiful is that we do
that for one another yes there's been
plenty of times where I'll go like
you're not doing that like it's a
beautiful loving yeah and she starts
laughing and I'm like that sounds like a
nightmare yeah you don't want to do that
yeah you hate that every time you do
that you hate it yeah and and she's
healed and she'll do the same for me
yeah she'll be like what do you do
because it's often with my family I'll
go like well you know and uh and and my
yeah I shouldn't say that but it's not
like oh God you know I mean I I'm
worried they won't they'll think that
she keeps me from them but the truth is
she just helps me realize like have a
boundary for example when I said I just
saw them in October I have no memory
like that I don't work in time like that
Val has to go you saw them two months
ago and I'll be like right yes and so
she helps me in that yeah and and yeah
she's really good at regulating me oh
yeah Ari does that for me also he'll say
um he'll he'll remind me yeah all right
no wait he's like that's comedian right
yeah
he's I can like sort I think I can
picture his face I've yes but maybe I'm
thinking of the wrong I don't want to
describe him I don't know why okay
[Laughter]
kind of like the worst burn it would be
impolite to describe him but that's not
what I meant he's a very very funny man
uh and a good man and a special it's
called Jew is on YouTube right now I'm
not I'm not making that up I Look to
Katie Katie edit all of this out I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding
um here we are the question we're on
your spirituality and we're going to
stay there but I am curious if you if
when your mom died did that give you
closure or did it is everything the same
does she still loom in your
Consciousness in a similar way well sir
I mean certainly not when she first died
I mean yeah no it was not by any means
she died and then I'm relieved and can
finally be myself and what I you know it
was really really I think a lot of
people might believe that by the way
it's like when they die they're gone yay
right yeah yeah and I don't think that's
how it works is what you're saying no
and you know actually I I think that
last time I was on it was maybe shortly
after my mom died I was in a really
um I was in a dark place but I don't
think it seemed like one you know I
don't I don't think hindsight dark yes
yeah yeah I well I always think it takes
like three years to know where I was at
any time it really kind of takes that
perspective to be like oh God yeah that
was now from where I am now I kind of
know the extent of what was happening
and just knowing I mean I was I was
really deep in eating disorders and had
a lot of alcohol issues during that time
and yet it was just like I think I was
kind of showing up being like Oh I'm
having fun like what you know it just
was so funny me too
whenever it was yeah I was also I hadn't
stopped drinking yet okay yeah
all these different things yeah you know
I was so self-conscious about it too I
was wondering if that was kind of why I
was feeling that of like I really want
to show up as myself and not be you know
um not have that kind of the the how I
presented before was just so inauthentic
to what I was actually feeling at the
time I'd like to be able to show up as
myself at any given time
um this is something I talked about
actually in therapy where she was like
oh but don't you know don't discredit
yourself and recognize that you're a
decade older and a decade of working on
yourself further and you know have some
self-trust she kind of encouraged me to
have so I try to remember that yeah yeah
but um no it was not it it was really
um
it was really heavy for a while it was
really
you know of course painful and complex
all the things that you I guess expect
grief would be and then I actually found
out
um in I found this is I guess a spoiler
but whatever um I found out that my dad
wasn't my biological dad a year and a
half after my mom died and that was sort
of the thing uh because my first
therapist had suggested that my mom was
abusive I quit that therapist because I
didn't want to believe that I didn't
want to yeah I didn't want to do
whatever work that entailed um it was
just intimidating
um and then and then little like I found
out the thing about my dad and then I
thought well who if my mom didn't tell
me that like who was she really that was
just sort of as I see it now the final
straw is that right the last straw the
final straw the straw yeah there's yeah
the last straw the last straw most of
human history we were [__] with straw
so a lot of metaphors about straws not
So Much Anymore
um and I and I and I you know I just
that there was something to that that
just made me think okay I gotta figure
out
I gotta figure out kind of who I am
separate from from the the you know
these people intentionally kind of
distancing myself from from my family
not saying I gotta figure out who I am
separate from my family but like these
people who are my family I have to
figure out who I am separate from that
because I can just get caught in the
undertow of this and the and the the
baggage of the pastor I can kind of just
start taking accountability for myself
you know and I could get I was really
caught in blame and anger for a while of
how how dare my mom not tell me this
about my dad [__] her I can't believe
she did this this is ridiculous now I
have to deal with all this who am I why
didn't my dad tell me sooner why didn't
my grandparents tell just so pointing
fingers toward everyone
um and and really really angry and I
think I'd been carrying that anger for a
long time before I even knew those
realities there was something in me I
think just from growing up the way that
I did where I was just angry you know
just had that that
unprocessed un exercised un on um
on
felt anger I guess you know I was trying
to suppress it for so long and then I I
really just kind of felt the anger you
know a lot
um and for a while and then kind of
started feeling what was underneath the
anger which was just so much pain and
disappointment and stay safe anger is
pain and disguise yeah yeah absolutely
um that I didn't want to believe for a
while
um when my therapist had told me that
like that there's stuff underneath the
anger I thought so much better yeah
that's more empowering and it's it's
motivating it it it's cool it's
literally a whole genre yes yes like but
if John Wick was like wait you're just
mad about my dog
I don't need to shoot all of these
people in the face I'm transmitting my
pain because I refuse to transmute it
that's a Richard Rohr if you don't
transmute your pain you transmit it
that's great isn't it good that's really
great yeah you just keep passing it
Forward oh my God into four John Wick
movies
there would be no franchise if he was
just like yeah mercy
no one wants Mercy
we want vengeance you know and I and I
think there's a a part of me that wanted
to to hold on to the anger because I did
think it was I thought that I could be
funnier with the anger I thought that I
you know the kind of roles that I played
out tended to be very angry people you
know and and I thought well that works
for me and also sad people it's
heartbreaking in your book when they're
like noticing your sadness yeah it's
like the worst part of this town it's
like she's so sad put her on camera like
look at the sadness in her eyes yeah
it's like it's like what the whole
country thinks we are and sometimes it
is what we are and we're like whoopsie
yes we're the worst yes yes horrible
yeah yeah yeah
um but then I think once I really I mean
I really started to get more honest with
myself about the anger and and the
sadness and the pain all the things
underneath it and and all my mistakes
and the things that I the the blaming I
had done and I think that was when I
started to actually feel some closure
which I think weirdly ties into the
self-forgiveness which I didn't want to
believe that could lead to for goodness
of other people because I think I just
feared what that would entail like oh if
I'm not if I don't have that chip on my
shoulder all the time what does that
even mean for who I am as a person like
if I don't carry that around what will I
be
um and yeah I mean I took took years and
I would say now I feel
I don't think there's ever going to be
like full closure with it I don't I
don't really know if that's possible
um
but I I am able to just miss her and to
not have it be a really complicated
experience that brings up anger and
wanting to throw things and then feeling
like my whole day's thrown off and then
feeling like I'm taking out on other
people like I'm able to just have it be
like oh I just miss her like literally
right right
that's so much better yeah I know I know
I should be like oh don't cry but it's
so beautiful because to mask it and
disguise it and to hide it yeah yeah
because because sadness is also one of
those feelings that we're supposed to be
like you know but it's like I'm so I
know it's not my place to be proud of
you but like I I'm proud of you as a
friend thank you and like that's what
the work looks like thank you because if
you were just if you were just [__] you
like I'd be like oh we just started the
journey yes we just started the journey
I feel the same exactly there's been a
lot of time being angry or or just
boundaries with my with my folks really
just being like this sucks and and me
really going at it hard and then just
being like getting a little bit more
honest you don't you don't don't read
angry at all like I don't pick up on any
of
that it's working I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding
um but you know I mean how I feel like I
don't know I like I feel like any time
if a person's really angry forward I
feel like it's just impossible to not
kind of like lead with yeah yeah it's
like it's the grapefruit and the fruit
salad the whole thing tastes yeah
grapefruit now I know what you mean I
appreciate that because it's the same
compliment I'm giving you is that like
to process it on the other side of it
there can be a calm recognition of
wrongs no denial yeah but also not no
need to exaggerate them or to hold on to
them yep yeah because you realize
I don't know if someone else has made
this metaphor but it's like you're
you're clinging to these rocks and
they're the rocks that are keeping you
sinking in the ocean yes and like you
don't want to let go of them because
damn it yeah these things happen yeah
but it is like what is it forgiveness is
giving up hope for a better past I
believe Lily Tomlin said that giving up
hope for a better past wow Lily Tomlin
said that's incredible yeah old little
and she said watch Grace and Frankie we
sell dildos
so people are lots of different things
how how do you feel with so forgiveness
this was this was
um
this was something that was really
important
um for me to hear I'll say it and I hope
it's helpful um for someone but I
because I had been so
um adamant about finding forgiveness for
my mom and that was sort of the goal you
know I love a goal I love a result and
and the the thing that I was going to
therapy for was I'm going to find
forgiveness for my mom and I'm going to
quit therapy and I'm going to be good
and I'm on my Merry way
um and my therapist Aaron had said
you know what if forgiveness isn't the
goal what if that's not what you're
aiming for what if you just kind of like
gave up on the idea of forgiveness and
that was I mean
it's transforming it like I remember
just kind of bending over myself and
really collapsing and feeling now as I
see it what I imagine when people talk
about forgiveness what I imagine that
weight is that's lifted when they
forgive I felt that by giving up by
giving up the idea of forgiveness can I
say yeah not to over spiritualize us
please because you you are Mercy um like
the ego forgives
your true self is just made of Mercy ah
the ego loves or has special love
but your true self is made of Love Is
Love so that surrender very smart who's
this therapist Aaron Mason
aaronmason.com
McCurdy that's the promo code
but that's good therapy right there yeah
it was it I mean wow yeah it was like it
was a a moment that I'll never forget
and it really changed my life yeah let's
note that as a uh the time sorry to
commercialize this but I'm like that's a
good little clip just because sometimes
people don't watch the whole episode
yeah sure just this clip yeah that's
really good yeah
um all right I have to pee
but I'm going to hold it okay oh my God
the story of you holding your poo as a
background actor again like if you if
you have kids do you want to have kids I
don't I don't but I'm open to my mind
changing and I recently have been
um kind of thinking I think I don't know
maybe I maybe I will there's like a
weird my friend Chris just said to me he
goes I don't believe in planned
pregnancies he's like just just see what
happens okay
um I guess that could be a controversial
statement but but their baby wasn't
planned and they're rolling with it and
I'm like do you want to have another one
and they're like we don't plan yeah it's
like I like that yeah yeah yeah so I
hear what you're saying
um and yeah it's not something to that
seems loaded I I it would kill me if
Leela thought I was like yikes it's just
it's a big thing it's a big thing that's
all I'm saying for sure it's a big thing
but when reading your book through the
lens of a parent is like this is
I can't handle the thought of Leela
holding her poop and it's just too much
now we're getting into pity I'm not
trying to pity you I'm just like the
thought of kids yeah too much sure no no
and I yeah a lot of a lot of a lot of
parents have said things about how yeah
they've I love I love hearing from
parents who have who have read it and
and yeah believe it or not even though
it's just like Troublesome Tale
too late to put that on the book a
Troublesome Tale
Pete Holmes oh my God
and it has a picture of me
why is this picture on the book
um it is it I think it will help people
in big ways and little ways just parent
better be more aware more conscious any
Memoir written from that age is gonna
help people go like oh right these are
people right these are people right
they're not purse dogs
okay
um
let's roll let's let's close is there
anything you didn't want to say I mean
that you did want to say that you didn't
get to say any area that you felt I cut
you off or something no no no no I feel
I feel good how do you feel I feel great
but that can sometimes be the worst sign
I don't read comments and stuff but
people will sometimes be like like I
remember I thought the Charlie day one
was so good and then I accidentally saw
the comments and they're like this host
needs to shut the [__] up and I was like
Yay oh God yeah they're not wrong but
they're not right either do people come
on is it YouTube or whatever yeah it'll
be on Instagram okay yeah that's why I'm
not I don't I don't uh do it anymore I
occasionally check my messages but yeah
just the verified ones I'm just kidding
maybe I'm not
um
what's your favorite breakfast cereal
just to cleanse uh
cinnamon toast crunch because it's the
right answer really what's your number
two because that is just the right
answer Reese's Puffs
Jesus Christ those are exactly are you
serious yeah really oh my God favorite
breakfast Heroes came up on a zoom
recently and I felt like such an odd
ball everyone was like talking about I
mean there was like Special K was
mentioned
that person that's a cry for help if
they're like I love special okay I'm
like I like special Caitlin are you
special okay are you okay you're not
okay
like are you in a that's like blinking
erratically to tell the FBI I don't I am
safe my favorite cereal is Special K do
not worry about me do not send rescue
like the FBI would be like he said
special okay we gotta move swarm swarm
which okay is good but so is total get
the [__] out of my house you know what I
mean we're not here to talk about total
turtle's toasted it has a nice toasty
taste
um crispix if we're gonna say like a
like a basic [__] cereal yeah
strangely good but the correct answer is
the flavor of Wheat Thins but the shape
of crispix and I don't like Christmas
no checks that's what I'm thinking yeah
yeah
is a great cracker don't get me serious
what's the shredded wheat one with the
sugar on top is it Shredded Wheat okay
yes yes he says those are so good also
love we these are the addict cereals
these are the ones that give you the
most I've got a layer of sugar on top
yeah she's like we know what you want
yeah yeah but wasabi peas is a breakfast
cereal called frosted many ways like
it's the most like
experience yes there's a narrative to it
those last ones are super soggy yes yeah
oh God one one Christmas I gave Val here
at this house I gave Val it was a big
box and it was just five cereals
she loves cereal
everyone loves cereal this is what made
this gift genius
it's the gift you didn't know you wanted
you open it up and there's just five by
the way steal this idea five sugar
cereals we I think we ate all of them in
like three days like we just housed them
do you not have sugar cereals on hand
regularly in fact I'll go ahead I'll
straight up judge you if I'm in your
house so I'll see you Count Dracula I'll
be like okay all right grow up that's
literally me and I'm worked all right
and what I'm wearing a dinosaur card
again I know no do you never grow up I'm
full of [__] in so many ways I'll judge
it but it's probably envy and it's
probably scapegoating because what I'm
doing is binging like I'll buy it and
eat all of it oh okay and I'm like
that's what a decent person does do it
in the shadows he's a he's a Dracula for
count for Count's sake
um so yeah just having it and
occasionally eating it but I couldn't
have it in my house if I had sent Toast
Crunch in my house
that I put on my coffee every morning I
do whipped cream on top of my coffee and
then I do the Cinna dust on top it's so
good Oh my Jesus
I yeah I have a thing with food because
I had such a difficult relationship with
it for so long um that I have no food
rules I eat whatever I want whenever I
want rules yeah no like I'm gonna not
have this you know good for you yeah and
I just I I have a half the time a very
childlike relationship with food that's
really important to me and then you know
and then yesterday I had a salad and a
green juice from Earth Cafe and I feel
like I'm yeah I literally have that when
I want that and when I don't want that I
completely don't have that and it's and
it feels yeah I love food and I love my
Santa dust everyone you're doing so good
see that's Cinna dust is forgiveness and
Earth bar no offense that's you know
that's like having the right amount of
hey Mom you could have done better you
know what I mean yeah sure sure but yes
the Extremes in either direction can be
so dangerous yeah the balance is is for
me with alcohol like I can't just like
sometimes have alcohol so you you need
to know your limits but I can sometimes
eat some cookies really so is that your
relationship with alcohol is that it's
very it's it's out it's out completely
only because Ghost of Christmas present
yeah if you give Pete a handle of vodka
I'll be like this every meal like every
meal for sure yeah
um and again it's not wanting to be
alive and and there's I wouldn't change
it about me in the world it's the same
guy that buys valve five boxes of cereal
or or has conversations like this it's
like let's more and more the two-hour
podcast let's go like that so I I've
learned like you that balance I'm not
like [__] addict Pete he's the worst
addict Pete is
why I got good at stand up or why I get
good at writing right you need
compulsive behaviors right sometimes
yeah yeah totally show me somebody that
we all that we all know about Michael
Jordan or yes or I'm trying to think of
somebody who hasn't been scandalized
yeah I was like Michael Jackson
but you know what I'm saying is like
they all had compulsive behaviors yeah I
had um
yeah the end yeah you're like you know I
also have to agree last question
well wow this has been such a great
episode I didn't get to any of the like
that post that says die UFO ghost nap or
advice what put what poster are you
looking at over there
but we'll just do the last question
which is better than all of those can
you think of a time in your life that
you laughed really really really really
hard uh maybe when you're a kid maybe
recently with Ari shaffir your boyfriend
Frankie Muniz uh but like some like
crying laughing
um and it doesn't have to be a good
story I always have to take the pressure
off it's just like who are you with what
happened did somebody fart somebody
usually farted or fell down no I
remember this from last time I remember
I don't think I had anything last time
either oh really yeah
let's do this ever see a ghost
ever see a ghost or a UFO or something
you can't explain however have a psychic
tell you something and it completely
comes true ever have a prophetic dream
um ever almost die
no I don't I don't think I don't think
I've had any of the no okay here's a
better one we never get to this one oh
tell me about a great nap you took you
have any like best nap of your life in a
weird place or it's perfect
um I've I've recently I I've never been
a napper
I used to really not like I used to not
be a good sleeper and thought thought it
was a waste of time and really was so
weird about it wake up in the morning
well that was a waste of time
that is the funniest way to start a day
it literally did nothing
that's literally how I felt I could have
been doing anything
what a waste of time it's truly hard on
myself about sleep like just it was yeah
but I I love sleep now I love like a
good nine hours like 10 hours is great
you're Cinder dusting I love it and I've
been napping on I've been doing a lot of
travel and I've been napping on
um airplanes there's no real uh story
here but I I love that you can nap on an
airplane and I love a nap where I drool
when I drool it's a really really good
it means I'm very comfortable I'm really
like deep in it and I've been drilling
napping on planes a lot
I love that you're like I better get
this out quick because he is going to
talk about drool I I can't wait I'll nap
on a plane and I'll wake up and it's so
uncomfortable and so unnatural and
you're in a chair like you're visiting
someone in the hospital it's the only
time you sit in the chair position
hospitals and planes you're in the chair
position that's so true you wake up and
you're like I didn't even nap and I'd
feel my mask and it's wet and I'm like
you now yes
you wet mask yeah I wear the mask I
don't care about covet I just want to
know if I know
um Jeanette I think the hardest laugh
might have been this episode we laughed
so much yeah I feel like we I'm just
complimenting us we talked about your
book but not not directly I really
appreciate how we talk about it like I
felt I felt really like like this was
fun and I felt engaged and I I didn't um
revert to a sound bite I didn't see you
do it once yeah the answer
the capital A answer oh let me get the
answer
oh God I'm so glad I'm proud of both of
us but here at the end I will plug we'll
plug it in the intro too but the book is
called it's not called I'm glad my mom
is dead don't call it that it's I'm glad
my mom died which is very different it's
so funny people do I'm glad my mother
has died like I've seen so many
different my mother wrote a porno it's
what that's a different podcast uh yeah
no it's hard it can be hard to hold in
your head but it's I'm glad my mom died
yes and it's a great audiobook because
people listen to this love listening to
things great performance there's also
just a great book uh check it out and
anything else you want to say I am just
so happy to be doing this with you and
thanks for having me oh it was awesome
truly one of my favorite episodes and I
think around the holidays yeah people
people are going to be needing this one
yeah yeah yeah people gonna be my
therapist said this is when she gets her
biggest uptick in appointments these two
weeks facts what was their name Aaron
Miller Aaron Mason Aaron Mason Aaron
Mason is my literary agent actually
really so edit that out I'm just kidding
Aaron Mason check her out.com slash
McCurdy and what you I don't know if you
remember from last time we have the
guests I keep at Christmas I remember
because I didn't remember I didn't know
then and I was mortified oh because you
were a big fan yes and I could not
believe that I didn't know here we are
and we went to this guy make it right
yeah well yeah that's your camera
keep it crispy
thank you so much thanks we could have
talked for nine more hours
[Music]